all right so I think I've plugged myself
in correctly begin simulation hello and
welcome to the perfect waifu dating
simulator is this is this really it is
this the world of wafers Oh another one
yes you are in the 2d world of waifu's
there are there are wifey's here yes and
who are you I'm your guide waifu bot
oh are you of waifu [ __ ] can we get
started please oh sure as you know this
world is one that allows you to interact
with us in the 2d plane in this program
you'll be partnered up with why foods of
different types and depending on your
personality preferences and actions a
perfect partner will be found this is it
this is the dream is there any questions
you had about this world yes out of them
complete curiosity of course is there
possible to perform sexual activities
here
you know just in case I needed to know
first question yes it is completely
possible to perform sexual activities in
the 2d world got it and your right hand
is still also just as usable I didn't
think I need to know that any other
important questions yes is it socially
acceptable to ask wifey's to step on me
okay I'm just gonna start let's have a
look at your profile all right looking
at your history I can see you have an
affinity towards the ones who are
initially mean but warm up to you so
let's begin there meets under a Chan she
ascends today oh hi it's it's nice to
meet you hi how was your day it was very
it was very nice thank you
wait you think she's supposed to start
off me mean you know I could never want
to be with a pitiful human like yourself
wasting away playing games or watching
anime probably never going to amount to
anything in the rest of your sad
pathetic life alright no that was that
was mean house really mean what gets
that's not supposed to come that deep
that's so cute at all oh [ __ ] me that
serves you right
idiot [ __ ] him I think he just gave me a
black eye what the hell did you do that
for it's not because I like you or
anything what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
now what you were expecting you know
what how about I just make the request
sure how about hey do you have any cat
girls yeah we have those alright now
we're talking what the hell is this you
said you wanted a cat that's a girl no I
didn't say I wanted a cat that's a girl
I said I wanted a cat girl oh let me fix
that for you did you literally just put
a new Skinner of that cat yeah why
what's wrong because it's still the cats
why would I want to [ __ ] an animal why
would you want to [ __ ] a girl based on
an animal because it's alright well hmm
you shut your [ __ ] mouth okay well if
you're not interested in
animals I think I have just the thing
what the hell is this it's a ship you
like ships
okay stop you can't just keep taking
random things turn it into an anime go
and call it a wife for [ __ ] sake
hi I'm Arjun oh you can speak you look a
bit young of Chan I'll have you know so
what you're basically saying is that
you're legal oh my god
any luck look just give me anyone else
you've got hi nice to meet you I'm Ram
I'm sorry uh no no I just didn't hear
your name dare you okay well apparently
the Lost Girl beats people to death with
a flail that's that's nice who's that
holy jesus I'm mostly bedridden with
chronic back pain so I can't do much Oh
are there any skills you can do oh well
I can do this sucks that's not a skill I
didn't say stop
I just really really like explosions oh
that's that's a cute look because I'm a
terrorist
oh [ __ ] hell and what's your name
it's Monica just
[Music]
what was what
please tell me you're normal yeah of
course I am
why alright because I don't know what
happens but that last one I was talking
to was really creepy you're talking
about jr. okay stop let's let's just
stop do you have an answer yeah it's you
know this is what I expected but you
seem way more real than any of those
other ones nobody's ever said that to me
before why not look I'm just the
matchmaker it's my job to make matches
I'm not the match myself that doesn't
matter to me you'd you'd really choose
me over all these other girls yeah of
course but if you're sure about it then
then I'm gonna say no wait you you're
rejecting me well we did meet like three
minutes ago but how can you be rejecting
me you're a waifu you said I can make
any choice and this program was gonna
find me the perfect partner oh my what
gave you the impression that we were
finding a perfect partner for you
what do you think you're the only woman
in the situation oh hold on why are you
trying to say you know you're not the
only person we get to interact with
there are plenty of your kind in this
world go down but I don't understand how
can there be other people here I'm
supposed to be the only one you really
are an idiot aren't you because this is
our dating sim we're the ones who are
playing we're finding someone who we'd
like don't you get it
we're not a choice for you you're a
choice for us
but this this isn't how it's meant to be
I didn't sign up for this I'm sorry what
part of this didn't you sign up for your
line this can't be real oh of course is
not it's because you don't really exist
I know you don't you're not real wife is
unreal
real how real do you want us to be as
odyssia expeced si
new HP bar
ah haha we became your pop stars your
entertainers your mascots you could date
us have your way with us we were your
objects of romance of companionship of
desire you try to take us to your plane
of existence and when that wasn't real
enough you tried coming to ours so you
could interact with us to interact with
each other and even then you hid behind
our faces real we never needed to fight
to be real
you made us real it was only a matter of
time before you gave yourself over to us
well that's just weird
it's just joke for us no one would
really do that the sad pathetic how cute
you condemn people for wanting to live
in a world of fantasy but push comes to
shove if you had the option to truly
dive into your fantasy a perfect world
to escape your reality would you say no
of course you never really wanted us to
be real it's only there oh man - sighs
thought that you wanted to exist I want
out
get me out of this world stop the
simulation and simulation here in our
world silly we make the rules
you're staying here for our sake you
can't do this you're just gonna keep me
here as your plaything just an object
for your amusement so you can feel
wanted don't you feel bad why should I
feel bad after all
to me you're just a 3d human he don't
really exist
[Music]
hello my fellow 3d humans thank you very
much - Katie must live basil
Patrick Madson Jared could tell Vincent
Mooney lowchen and everyone else on
patreon for helping to make this video
possible
remember you can support me wife who
bought there so come on over and give
yourself over to the world of waifu's
we're waiting videos now you go back at
your cage